hey this is summer Wayne this is
actually the second episode that I shot
yeah don't look you have any grabby
mouth you haven't even called even see
this ever son then you have to don't you
have to see this officer you have to see
this episode now you know what does my I
might have even shown this before
because I knew this one had the funniest
opening like intro to the characters and
that's them going to the Halloween store
breaking everything and then Stan giving
her fake money and throwing a gas bomb
and running away it's stealing it all
and I was like that and that's gonna be
a nice dinner she was the street fighter
episode I saw first it could be a time
serve because I'm but positive I saw
this second but I loved I love this one
because it's a Halloween episode even
though it's not over Halloween um and I
thought that's a funny way around there
they like Halloween so much I had to
have it twice and then make it you know
melon lanterns but I do agree that scene
in the intro where he drops the gas bomb
it just runs away is just grunkle Stan
my grunkle Stan and Mabel yeah the nose
al yeah my bell mouth yeah ale my bell
yeah they're my favourite characters I
think yeah they're the ones that is
dippers somewhere probably just in the
middle like I think it's cuz he's like
the straight guy oh like everybody
else's way he's gotta be the me honestly
as in folks I don't go welcome fault a
man honest a more interest in him than a
lot of main characters on a lot of shit
that's why it's got like Harry Potter
says ELISA interesting part is Harry
Potter and Harry Potter it could be
worse he could be a Leonardo from
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles yeah whose
favorite was ever Leonardo yeah I'll
watch I'll have all these do it
yeah fucking dare you sir I'm not
watching anymore
I thought yes Leanne I thought we ads I
thought we got each other I think in my
entire life I have not met one person on
the planet yet who said that Leonardo
was the favorite
I've met Donatello's wrong yeah my god
Talan I've let splinters like April was
my favorite or even cray-cray nobody
likes leave out paroxetine nobody nobody
in my entire life has ever said Leonardo
so dipper is way better than that there
you go the recommendation of a lifetime
dippers bear that leave no no um but in
this episode they gotta love this way
this is what I would watch every
Halloween honestly I know I totally
agree with you like I got well I saw it
after Halloween and I got kind of upset
because I'm like damn it
I would have loved to have seen this
like right before Halloween yeah it's
like a legit good Halloween episode
because they they go around um on second
Halloween a dipper is trying to not want
to do all the way because these I gave
trying to impress Wendy and they have
this subplot about which always is kind
of annoying but yeah but they have a
subplot about loser Nancy which is what
what a great observation cuz that's true
there is Lew Tyrion oh then the extents
they go to the loser candy the the
saying at the end of this one uh is
brought you by homework the candy I
means I'm a lobby daddy's in there at
salerio
like Oh loser candy like them sweet
hearts sweet tarts are definitely like
one of my raisins what but there's what
we see asshole with us you ladies with
raisins raisins it's nature's candy yeah
that's a Marge Simpson yeah um fruit is
nature's candy uh I what I didn't even
like Raisinets I'm like you're trying to
disguise the fact that this is health
food good chocolate ain't gonna work
yeah Raisinets yes sweet sweet tarts for
a big one I didn't like pixie sticks no
pixie sticks Oh bring us the chocolate
man we need the chocolate a lot of the
hard candies you can suck on I wasn't a
huge fan of either it sometimes nerds
can all know actually nerds I loved I
actually don't think nerds are loser
candy
even though they're called nerds that oh
by the name their loser candy what do
you got against nerds huh now your fans
are mostly nerds you just insulted our
entire fanbase
oh well you know what you're not losers
well some of you are but not all of you
it's not your fault it's not your fault
that's your fault they're not nerds
they're geeks or now they're however
that definition wait everyone's like are
you a nerd or a geek it's like what are
you talking about
you want to build any Ardea gek it's
it's okay
let's that's a little fun um but yeah so
yeah no visible bottle caps bottle caps
bottle caps yeah uh um oh the weird
honey it's like talking about this arm
yes yes because this brought up a very
important point if you're giving out
candy on Halloween don't be that loser
candy candy corn chorus course candy
corn oh oh well Lewis blacks are the
best all candy corn was made in 1908 and
they've been just recycling and washing
it down nobody have it um but yeah the
the weird do you remember like the weird
honey nougat type of can't like throw me
on it yes yeah I never even like shit
don't pass that out um so just guess
it's not mini candy bars so so why is it
so difficult so this character called
the trickster uh tells them that you
know to keep in the spirit of summerween
uh you have to go get this giant amount
of candy so Mabel and her friends with
dipper go get all this candy while he's
you know think he's gonna go this party
with Wendy thanks daily lose all the
candy and it turns out that the
trickster was always loser candy
compiled together in this giant ray or
did away giant buddies you can bring
this up okay yeah I already was up so
Doug as the episode starts goes like no
this episode is really cool because they
have this homage to something that's a
little more obscure and like it'll take
you a while to get it but when you get
it when you get it you're gonna be like
wow the second paper comes on it's like
oh it's no face your spirited away
the sexy shows about oh it's no facing
straight away and dumb just goes like
fuck you looks just like no maybe how
the fuck it's clearly no face from the
second half of the movie uh he has just
like some a pitch yeah I'm like oh
that's queer yeah it's like cuz he's got
the giant spider arms and he's the big
man in it yeah you were he was really
really says it so many like what's in
that hidden maybe for you older smarter
taller brother uh at your thing up to
air or may were about the same I thought
we decided I'm actually Mabel um oh oh
so I need to know how long did it take
good well any okay I had a theory when
he started climbing up the thing like
that but it wasn't clear to me until he
actually got the mouth and was with the
mask and everything but yes he climbed
the thing like oh that's no face I'm
like I saw a bitch Josh I'm good
deduction work there laughs fuck off um
so honestly there really are so many
good lines with this one uh you know I
just ate a man alive today oh it isn't
about the treats or the candy or the
being together it's about something very
evil pure evil um well this is a good
one that had a lot of lines but a good
stories well we were just talking about
how sometimes I've noticed that if we
can remember all the lines it's not
always a good story this is that rare
one where it's like yeah well then oh
this one had a lot of really good ones
at the end especially I think it's why
Vermeer because those were from the a
that's true yeah and I just love the
idea that's loser candy compile it and
the design of the thing really see you
it has Joey is really parents who pass
out loser candy you see what you're
wreaking on the world what have you
wrought you know and the kind don't buy
Chiclets nobody eats them stop handing
out peeps on Halloween gumballs are
acceptable Chiclets know people who hand
out toothbrushes and dental floss you're
going to help
oh no that yes straightforward there's
no debating it Satan's like oh that's
oh no you are worse than Hitler if you
do that yeah you're gonna be in a room
next to your guys share a room with
hitler and don't lose gonna be like you
passed up two fists on Halloween shut
the fuck what's wrong with you
that's just kids six million people but
Jesus yeah you're sick don't don't do
that don't we're passing out loser candy
is like passing out little Hitler dolls
little Hitler candies yeah you ride with
Hitler when you pass because that tastes
like pickles or something
yeah our crap yes no so much funnier
than mine okay no but you know and the
kind of uh moral in this one with
different line to Mabel so I like this
one this is the first time Mabel like
won't speak to dipper and that was the
one thing else are concerned about joint
to you like was the first ones is that
that really was kind of like a while
like she she won't talk to him like that
is kind of like yeah he's always so
talkative and so positive that when you
see it is just kind like whoa oh no
actually that's a really good point and
what I like too is that I do sorta like
that talk it's like she knows that okay
I know we're gonna get to a point where
we can't we're not getting triggered a
more I just didn't know like this was
the last one and it's Kylie we put at
perspectives calico feels she's I think
it was worth fifteen sixteen we went a
good at all just because you went to
high school doesn't mean you can't trick
Eddie yes don't say shit is that what
look that with eight area is like wait I
can just do this
I could buy candy whatever I want I
didn't realize the coffee's kicking in
I'm all hyper we're Bharath outing these
all well you can tell cuz we're we're in
the sense hanging out you can tell when
we've started a new day will be in like
you know dick of attire um but but we
had but yeah but again even though it
was a touch force I still like I kind of
felt that I felt that connection with
them uh in that see it I thought that
was actually kinda like a nice sweet bit
um ya know this is a really really solid
episode yeah like I said it's what I
probably will watch every Halloween cos
it's just surrounded in Halloween stuff
well and it gets to what I was saying in
the early reloads it's the atmosphere on
this year
and I don't know why it reminds me of
like the old LucasArts games like secret
of mud Secret of Monkey Island in
particular there's like a lot of videos
goofy hand-painted little details
everywhere whittles and it had a lot of
shadows a lot of darkness about you what
they was a very colorful humor it was
still very cool and a lot of atmosphere
and I kind of feel like with all the
stuff they throw into it there's a
picture of the mystery shack on the TV
that's why I keep it looking over here
with all the stuff they pack into it
like yeah you do just want to like pick
things up and like play it as a game
like yeah
what is this dule probably would be a
fun game if they like really would they
should do like an old Lucas art style
adventure game but gravity falls gravity
that would be awesome Ron Gilbert get on
it assistive so um ya know a really
great episode I love this uh I wonder if
anyone cosplays as the trickster I'd be
great somebody get on that you get
somebody do in hospitals gosh yeah
that'd be great
uh and see how many people confuse you
for now for no face yeah and see how
fast it takes us figure it out if it's
like dug it may take them like 20
minutes so fuck you rob but anyway back
to loser candy for candy bars three
musketeers are not the best I'm just
saying they're like the healthy candy
bar the lighter water selling you don't
want Manuel yours and I'd like to hurt
for your Snickers your butterfingers way
Twix
Twix are amazing mounds hell yeah Risa I
don't even go with them you know there's
this rhesus a candy bar they have now
that's really good after you it's called
but oh you know it's onna take five shit
I don't want pretzels in my frickin
candy bar whatever the hell that's made
of yeah are you know the little bags of
like that yeah like you said it's like a
makes us that or just pretzel or so
sound like that's like no no I would
even accept like your little mister good
bars Hershey's oh those are good hey I
love those the crackle ones those are
good yeah crackles good though it is
just the poor man's Nestle's crunch
Nestle's crunch damn good yeah damn good
let's go get some candy good with the
cookies